sixers hoping to win it here  [Applause]  spurs do not have a foul to give  tobias harris who's been quiet  and being again against shang  [Applause]  joel into action and bead for the lead  simmons the tip did it come before the  expiration of time  did the officials allow it presumably  they did because the final scoreboard  shows  113 to 111 but the replay will bear it  out  [Applause]  [Music]  the advantages of having a 610 point  guard  who crashes down the stretch  first one to it absolutely in time  pack your bags we are headed to chicago  mark  it wasn't pretty but a w is a w  and that w puts the sixers now firmly  into first place  a half game ahead of the brooklyn nets  who lost this afternoon  to the bucks in milwaukee